vous prenez mon argent monsieur vous me
traiter de sale [ __ ] a en outre été de
noir mais c'est ben oui c'est normal je
peux que vous êtes des menteurs d'accord
donc ont aidé on aidé des macaques ont
et des menteurs c'est bien ça vous êtes
vraiment exceptionnel on est tellement
ridicule que vous demandez à propos
patron mais vous êtes mais tellement
ridicule non seulement vous êtes
confiance dans le travail dans le calme
mais ça vous a pas servi de leçon
m'entendez est-ce que vous m'entendez
missiles d'accord on peut communiquer
normalement vous m'entendez non oui
d'accord vous êtes en train d'imiter mon
vécu et la brute inc des glaçons je suis
pour l'agresseur à cergy c'est non mais
c'est ça fait ainsi les mêmes tagro
c'est vrai encore qu'on entend donc là
il avoue menacé aussi physiquement par
lui donner quoi passer - votre votre
adresse jeu arrive en scooter je vous
écraser comme georges floyd c'était
vraiment des menaces des mort c'était
c'était incroyable
c'est c'était choquant c'est je vois que
vous aviez regardé tous les deux votre
calme lors de l'appel téléphonique vous
êtes extrêmement calme en plus c'est
incroyable parce que je trouve je joue
je suis admiratif de votre calme parce
qu'il y en a plein qui se serait parti
vraiment encore plus loin et qui est
vraiment bravo à vous parce qu'un
contraire ses côtés il ya un téléphone
le propriétaire bien sûr donc il est
même pas courageux ils affrontent pascal
ratthé ans et vous êtes menacé de porter
plainte
et cet homme vous fait clairement
comprendre à vous et en votre âme et
votre future femme sait pas vous mais
c'était pas vous là en fait là nous en
fait quand ça s'est passé le 24 mai
l'avait enfin le lendemain du coup on a
appelé hier et c'était nous deux
d'accord et la voilà c'est là que ça a
commencé là oui là il y avait là vous
êtes d'abord avec une amie voilà et
après ça c'est peut-être ces deux jours
après ma grave qu'il est parti avec une
amie à moi pour aller là sont les
écouter ce qui vous dit vraiment que les
noirs ont un ennemi mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas bien c'est qu'on n'a pas que
c'est la justice
ça la justice s'est désolé mais c'est
comme ça vous n'avez pas réglé la mise
en peinture en violant vous tabac sont
vos insultes
condamné pour avoir tabassé un mois tout
s'est tellement battu et la cgc a rien
de leur retard vous avez très bien fait
en tout cas d'enregistrer les
conversations
vous avez été je pense être extrêmement
choqué par ce que vous avez entendu
c'est seafood entendre des propos comme
ça et ce qui est plus grave c'est que
ces faits deux histoires eh oui deux
histoires jour celle assez similaires et
des insultes similaire quelques jours et
là je m'adresse à vous m il faut qu'ils
aient des sanctions faut absolument
porter cette affaire en justice faut
qu'ils aient des sanctions et je pense
qu'il faut des sanctions exemplaires
évidemment et très vite et nous on va on
va suivre la faire et on dira vraiment
s'il ya eu des sanctions si on n'a pas
eu on le dira ici parce que ce serait
inadmissible
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour
l'instant on est tous pour l'instant il
ya des plaintes qui ont été déposées
pour injure mais aussi pour menaces de
mort il ya aussi un délit qui s'appelle
le délit de discriminer qui est prévu
par le code pénal et nous ce qu'on veut
aujourd'hui c'est que ce délice sept
personnages soient poursuivis dans le
cadre de ce délit de discriminer votre
plante a été prise au sérieux voilà très
sérieusement c'est suivi en ce moment là
parquet de paris qui est saisie de la
sphère qui en charge de la faire on doit
les remettre tous les enregistrements à
la police
très prochainement et les investigations
vont se porter sur la recherche de
l'identité de l'auteur parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un numéro de
téléphone mais on ne sait pas qui se
cache derrière ce téléphone